*lautes Klatschen*
Oh! *lacht*
Okay das war zu laut, nochmal!
[Hamza] Ich schwör's dir, du hast grade Thanos von Avengers gemacht!
[Kiki] Okay!
Hallo ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute ein lecker-leichtes Dessert
und zwar einen... ich würde mal sagen Blechkuchen mit Streuseln!
Und das, was bei diesem Rezept besonders ist, ist halt die Füllung
denn das ist eine sehr locker-leichte Baiser-Joghurtfüllung
und ich werde wahrscheinlich noch Früchte mit einrühren.
Das Rezept habt ich zugegebenermaßen diesmal von meiner besten Freundin, Grüße gehen raus an Büşi!
Und sie ist meine beste Freundin seit der 2. Klasse
und ich hab das letztens von ihr probiert, sie hat's mir mitgegeben.
Ich hab's jetzt aber ein bisschen abgewandelt nach meinem Geschmack.
Und daher würde ich sagen legen wir direkt mal los!
Ich werde jetzt zuallererst meine Eier trennen.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr wirklich das Ei sauber trennt.
Es darf kein bisschen Eigelb ins Eiweiß rüber.
Das ist super wichtig und das machen wir jetzt als erstes.
Oh..boah!
Oh, fast wär mir das jetzt passiert!
*lacht*
Jetzt fange ich an mit dem Boden und den Streuseln und dafür brauchen wir jetzt unser Eigelb.
Zum Eigelb gebt ihr Zucker, zimmerwarme Butter und Mehl
und anschließend einfach mit den Händen durchkneten.
Davon ist jetzt die Hälfte für den Boden reserviert und die andere Hälfte bilden quasi die Streusel.
Also ich find's mega praktisch weil man eben nicht 2 Teige anrühren muss
und das auch jetzt super schnell mit den Händen zusammengeknetet war.
Ich werde jetzt anfangen, zuallererst mal den Boden auszukleiden
und dafür hole ich mir jetzt meinen Backrahmen.
Mit der Hälfte des Teigs hab ich jetzt den Boden ausgekleidet, also einfach mit den Fingern unten andrücken.
Ich hab untendrunter noch ein Backpapier und meinen Backrahmen auf die kleinste Stufe gestellt
das schreibe ich euch aber unten in die Videobeschreibung, genauso wie alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Jetzt geht's zur ultra fluffigen Füllung!
Wir haben ja hier unser Eiweiß.
Da habe ich jetzt die Küchenmaschine, ihr könntet auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Da kommt jetzt noch eine gute Prise Salz rein,
dann schlage ich das ½min an, also 30sek ungefähr und dann kommt Zucker hinzu
und wird nochmal so eine ganze bis 1½min richtig schön zu einer Baisermasse aufgeschlagen.
So, zur Baisermasse geben wir jetzt Vanilleextrakt, das ist quasi unser Hauptakteur.
Also das wird ein richtiger Vanille-Joghurt-Traum!
Das gibt am Ende auch den ausschlaggebenden Geschmack.
Das könnt ihr natürlich auch schon vorher mit reingeben wenn ihr Zucker mit dazu gebt.
Und anschließend brauchen wir Mehl zum Binden.
Das bitte unbedingt reinsieben und dann nur ganz vorsichtig mit 'nem Teigschaber unterheben.
Und zu guter letzt kommt da noch der Joghurt mit dazu.
Und noch ein kleiner Tipp: Das Mehl ruhig in mehreren kleinen Schritten mit dazu geben!
Wer möchte, kann jetzt noch Früchte dazugeben. Ich hatte noch extra welche ausm Tiefkühler geholt
und antauen lassen damit die Flüssigkeit so ein bisschen...
damit ich die abschöpfen kann.
Aber Hamza hat gesagt: "Kiki, mach doch heute ohne Früchte!"
[Kiki] Da hab ich mir gedacht: "Alles Klärchen!"
[Hamza] Das wird mir zu sauer glaub ich!
Hamza sagt das wär zu sauer. Ihr könnt's gerne reinmachen, also es ist eine schöne Option.
Gerne auch frische Früchte, dann aber auf den Boden legen und die Joghurtmasse obendrauf geben.
Ich gebe jetzt die Joghurtmasse auf meinen Boden und gebe dann die Streusel obendrauf.
[Hamza] Ich hab das Sagen in der Beziehung! *lacht*
So, die Streusel sind jetzt auch verteilt und jetzt backen wir unseren...
Kuchen, dessen Namen ich mal wieder nicht weiß! Wie nennen wir den überhaupt?
[Hamza] Büşi-Kuchen!
[Kiki] Den Büşi-Kuchen!
Nee, ich lasse mir da was Schönes einfallen!
Den backen wir jetzt bei 180°C Ober- und Unterhitze und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Oh, schwer!
Oh nein, das ist ja - das ist ja ein locker-leichter Kuchen!
Bei mir war der Kuchen jetzt für ungefähr 42min im Backofen.
Also ich würde ab 38-39min einmal reinschauen.
Obendrüber darf es nicht zu dunkel werden sondern wirklich nur so richtig goldbraun.
Und dann habe ich hier mit meinem Backformlöser einmal die Ränder gelöst weil die sich doch ganz schön festsetzen an den Backrahmen.
Und fertig ist der Kuchen!
Wenn ihr möchtet, macht gerne noch ein bisschen Puderzucker obendrauf oder lasst es einfach so.
Ich persönlich mag ihn sehr, sehr gerne weil eben durch den Joghurtanteil der Kuchen jetzt auch nicht so schwer im Magen liegt
oder man einfach kein schlechtes Gewissen hat!
Und ich wünsche euch ganz, ganz, ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen
und ich freue mich natürlich wenn ihr mir euer Feedback nachdem ihr das mal ausprobiert habt hier unten in die Kommentare schreibt.
Wer jetzt noch Hamzas Taste Test sehen möchte - auf den bin ich nämlich gespannt, denn von mir hast du den nicht probiert - kann gerne dranbleiben.
Und ich würde mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal, Tschüss!
[Hamza] So! Ladies und Gentlemen, we have here a Kuchen... a cake!
[Hamza] Very, very beautiful but uhm... I want to taste it and uhm... yes!
[Hamza] Cool! Let's start, let's begin!
[Hamza] So Leute! Wir probieren jetzt den Streuselkuchen.
[Hamza] Wir haben den vor einigen Tagen gegessen von der lieben Büşi.
[Hamza] Die heißt eigentlich Büşra, nur zur Info!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Und ich teste das mal jetzt aus. Also bei dir ist die Füllung ein bisschen niedriger, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Bei Büşi wär die ein bisschen größer, also höher.
[Hamza] Okay, dann mal...
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Oh mein Gott!
[Kiki] Okay, jetzt sag! Ich bin gespannt!
[Hamza] Nein, Spaß beiseite Leute!
[Hamza] Es fühlt sich so an, als ob man einen gesunden Kuchen isst!
[Kiki] Nee, echt?
[Hamza] Also natürlich: Streusel ist bisschen süß, das merkt man. Also was ich bemerkt habe...
[Hamza] Ich glaube das ist weil du's aufgeschlagen hast und dieses Unterheben gemacht hast, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] ..ist das schon so recht luftig, ne? Dafür, dass das Joghurt ist, weil Joghurt ist ja meistens eher fest.
[Hamza] Man merkt einfach, das ist keine -
*Handy Benachrichtigungston läutet*
[Kiki] Ups, Tschuldigung!
[Kiki] Die Büşi hat geschrieben!
[Hamza] Ey, ich bin - ich!
[Kiki] Okay, okay, es geht weiter, es geht weiter!
[Hamza] Ich bin gerade im Taste Test und dann kommt sowas - nee, das geht gar nicht, nee!
[Kiki] Okay, tschuldigung!
[Hamza] Also ich hab mich to-tütü, weißte?
[Kiki] Was? *lacht*
[Hamza] Also! Was wollte ich nochmal sagen? Ich bin jetzt voll raus ey!
[Kiki] Du wolltest sagen es ist nicht so wie Sahne und so!
[Hamza] Also man merkt hier auf jeden Fall an dem Kuchen: Es ist kein schwerer - es ist keine schwere Füllung.
[Hamza] Es ist nicht so mascarpone-/ frischkäselastig oder sonst was, sondern durch das Joghurt...
[Hamza] ...finde ich das schon recht -
[Kiki] Den Joghurt!
[Hamza] Durch den Joghurt. Sorry ähm Mrs... ähm.. Sorry Mrs. Kikis Kitchen!
[Hamza] ..den Joghurt ist es schon recht leicht vom Geschmack her.
[Hamza] Also ist mal was anderes, ne? Also man erwartet jetzt irgendwie, dass da Frischkäse drin ist aber da ist Joghurt drin!
[Hamza] So Leute, macht's unbedingt nach. Ich find's cool, ich find's lecker!
[Hamza] Ich wünsch euch einen schönen Abend, schönen Tach! Genießt es und liked.
[Hamza] Peace and out!
[Hamza] Mmmh!